>>Fernando Nilo - Davos Debates 2009
Hi YouTube community. My name is Fernando
Nilo. I am a [inaudible] entrepeneur from
[inaudible] and I'm here in Davos and I would
like to share my dream, mass ideas with the
community. We are recycling the e-waves, the
new ways of the century. Fax, scanner, DVD,
cellular, whatever you think it is electronics
are at the end of the line. In our labor jobs,
is the people who are in jail. They get the
freedom, nobody offer the job and then we
offer them a second chance at life. We are
recycling both people and the new ways of
the century. We would love to communicate
with you, to invite, to recycle property.
To invite to win the global warming problem
with recycling. Recycling is solution for
the future. I would love to turn people, entrepeneurs,
CEO, OEM, everybody to think about the green
seal, looking for recycling and this is our
future. We should build together, a better
world together.